as we head to orlando and bucks head
coach mike budenholzer coach
thank you ernie congrats to giannis on
being named defensive player of the year
his commitment to defending his
commitment to winning
is beyond incredible he impacts the game
with his blocked shots
his rebounding his ability to guard all
five positions
his chase down blocks his challenge to
do everything defensively
his talent is beyond special and
combined with his team
it's made for a very special moment and
for us to recognize him as the defensive
player of the year
so brooke give him the award
giannis give us your thoughts on that
congratulations young man
and you got it from brook lopez one of
your teammates and you guys got the
number one defensive rating in the nba
so what does this mean to you
you know first of all um thank you coach
senior brooke
um first of all i want to thank god
uh you know without god
uh i wouldn't be in this position i want
to thank him for
allowing me to wake up every day uh
being able to give him the opportunity
to go out there and achieve my goals in
life
my dreams i want to thank my family for
always motivated me
supporting me being there for me
thriving
all no matter when or those they're
always there for me
i want to thank coach the coach staff
you know for bringing the best out of us
every single night you guys give us the
game plan you make it easy for us to go
out there and compete and
you know uh you know give it our best um
you know i won't thank my teammates man
um
you know without my teammate this
wouldn't be possible um
i know that my name is on this trophy
but it could be any of this guy's name
on this trophy
you know i believe that defense is
building uh you know trust
an effort we trust one another we care
about one another
you know we believe in one another
that's why we're the best defensive team
in the nba
i'm going to keep it that way um man
guys thank you man i really appreciate
you guys
guys brooke thank you for having my back
every single night man
man brooke oh man um
and i want to thank the box organization
i said i'm not going to cry sorry guys
i want to take the the box organization
the medical staff
with fans for alliance to be great and
go out there and do what we love
[Music]
do what we dream of dreamed of
and so that's all i have for you guys
man